in the short term it has already been
paid dividends since the president Trump
announced a couple of weeks ago that he
was on the verge of being indicted uh so
uh it's very clear uh that this will uh
further uh help him in the primary
there's no question already the
Republican reaction has been a very very
strong much more strong the Democrat
reaction so forth as is being outrageous
and calling for Congressional
investigations and labeling it a
political persecution in the country
entering into stage of becoming really a
Banana Republic
and therefore I think he will Garner
support among Republicans and possibly
among Independents and Democrats if this
indictment and eventually uh whatever
trial or whatever ensues next if it
falls apart it will then be perceived as
political persecution and could really
uh put him in a position to win the
White House in 2024